as far as russia's military power goes
this has been a very sobering experience
for the russian military
[Music]
what the russians have achieved so far
is to conquer about two-thirds of the
donbass region which they say is the
most important thing for them and to
establish this land bridge between the
donbass and crimea which was the
territory that they
conquered and annexed illegally in 2014
so they've taken about 20 of ukrainian
territory but remember that this war
began with putin's intention to occupy
the whole of ukraine to throw the
government out to install his own
government and effect effectively to
absorb ukraine into a greater russia
that has completely failed they are
two-thirds of the way through occupying
the donbass but elsewhere it's not going
terribly well and the russians look as
if they are going to be caught over the
winter with all of their military
objectives only partly achieved
president putin has no military
background he was a regional kgb officer
in dresden just one small city that was
his governmental role until effectively
he became prime minister like all great
dictators he thinks that he's some sort
of military genius and in fact i mean
what military
decisions he has made or we know that he
has made generally speaking have proved
to be disastrous again like all
dictators people are frightened to tell
him the truth and he was not being told
the truth we think by his military
chiefs gerasimov um by his intelligence
chiefs before the war began and he seems
to have had a very delusional grasp of
what the situation in ukraine really was
and as he has tried to as well galvanize
his military it looks as if they've made
the problem worse
although they've got modern naval and
air forces their army is still
relatively unreformed and having gone
into battle now for the first time
since 1945 it's proved how poor it
really is conducting big operations and
so that's been an eye-opener not just to
those of us in the west who look at
these things but particularly to the
russian higher command who thought that
they were much better than they've
turned out to be the russians have
called in troops from every other
theatre that they've been involved in in
order to send them to ukraine and so
russian forces opposite the baltic
states estonia latvia lithuania are
thinner now than they've been for many
many years russian borders are more open
now than they've been for a very long
time because they've had to concentrate
those competent and professional troops
that they have into ukraine what the
russians are facing is a situation where
if they get bogged down in ukraine for
the next few years that their army is
far far too small to perform the various
other jobs which are big power
continental power like russia must have
not least they don't have many troops
looking after the border with china and
believe me that's a border that really
worries them if they're worried about an
invasion of the homeland they should
look at the number of chinese troops the
other side of the usuri river
ukraine is fighting for its life so in
principle ukraine can hang on for a very
long time it's a big country the biggest
country in europe apart from russia
itself population of 44 million people
they say they can put a million people
under arms and that's plausible they
certainly think they can put 700 000
people three-quarters of a million or so
under arms by this time next year that
means that they've got plenty of ability
to carry on and sustain themselves but
they can only sustain themselves and
carry on fighting if the west carries on
backing them with weapons and support
and money and that's the big if if the
west does not lose its nerve and if the
west is prepared to take some real pain
from here on in to support ukraine then
ukraine can carry on at least as long as
russia can and maybe longer
the present war i think may end in some
sort of ceasefire perhaps next year
perhaps the year afterwards and so
anything short of throwing this
adventure out preventing the russians
from gaining anything out of this
adventure anything short of that will be
a victory for putin and for sure if they
gain even a little bit of territory from
ukraine this time round they'll
certainly be back for more quite soon
there is every chance that this will
become an open-ended war which will last
for 50 60 70 years which is to say it
won't be a war all of that time it will
be a struggle in which russia refuses to
recognize the right of ukraine to be an
independent state and ukraine has to
live with the uh the reality that on
their border is a is a state a country
ten times bigger which actually wants to
conquer them and so what i suspect will
happen is that this struggle will go
through a series of on off uh conflicts
so there'll be a conflict there'll be a
ceasefire the cease-fire will hold for a
few years then break down the conflict
will break out again
this is a struggle which will carry on
in europe on and off on and off for two
or three more generations and we've got
to prevail we've got to protect
ourselves protect our liberties and
learn to prevail in this conflict so
that russia whoever the leaders are in
20 30 40 years time get the message
that western europe will stand up for
its own democratic principles
you